april's nice weather usually nice
weather is a perfect time for lots of
homeowners to get out and dig into yard
projects but before you put a shovel in
the dirt or you bring in heavy equipment
one simple phone call could spare you
and maybe your neighbors too some
utility head headaches according to
southwest gas nearly half of all active
diggers don't take the time to find out
where the utility lines are buried
beneath the top soil of their projects
and it's as easy as calling 8-1-1
calling 8-1-1 before you dig is just a
free and easy service to help people
like you homeowners who may be
do-it-yourselfers
excavators and contractors you just call
this eight one one easy to remember
number at least two working days before
you start your project they come out
they have the lines marked and then you
know where it's safe to take and where
it's unsafe to take keeps you and your
family safe it avoids damages injuries
outages it's just a very convenient
layer of safety
that's joanne arbaio with southwest gas
she says that
less than half of the
neighborhood so it's definitely
these two days before you start
come out and mark those lines and you
saw those drawn there in the video it's
really important to note that southwest
gas will only mark the lines
of oh on your property up to where the
gas meter sits so backyard projects they
will not go in your backyard and mark
the lines you'll have to have a plumber
do that so just so you know but front
yard projects anything there where
southwest gas can get to right they'll
be happy to come out and do that uh and
it really is important i mean you
rupture a line oh we've had new stories
about it yes it's it's not it's
avoidable right it absolutely is and
your neighbors are not gonna be happy
with you if you do that you sure won't
neither wear your wallet